BILL DUANE: So
welcome everybody.
We have some folks here
in the room, and then
lots of folks on Livestream.
This is a continuation
of a program
we did a week and a half ago
on self-care and mindfulness
in particular, the role of
compassion and self-care
and mindfulness.
And so this is needed now.
So my name is Bill Duane, and
I look after the Well-Being
and Sustainable Performance
programs here at Google.
And during my
team's team meeting,
we took time to do a check-in
on how is our own well-being.
And for many of us, most of us,
actually, it was pretty bad.
It was sort of remarkably bad.
Lots of emotional distress.
And just to put a name to
it, the particular cause
for the distress was
two further incidents
of black men being
killed by police
and the issues of systemic
racism in our justice system
that that represents.
And then, of course,
there have been
the sort of like litany
of other stuff going on.
It just seems like every
time you watch the news,
the rate of these things
is rapidly increasing.
So not all of us,
but a number of us
felt sort of distinctly not OK.
And on top of that, given that
we're the well-being team, when
we unpacked it, we
realized that we felt bad
about feeling bad, right?
We're just like, oh, I don't
want to feel like this.
We shouldn't feel like this.
And of course then it's
possible to feel bad about that.
And it's feeling bad
all the way down.
So one is, I just wanted to
start off the introduction just
acknowledging that if
that's where you're at,
you're not alone.
It seems like there's
something really different
and-- this is an odd way to
use the word-- but special
about this time that makes
it something different.
And that specialness
has a lot of potential
to think differently
about the way things are.
But in the short term, there's
also the very practical need
to tend to our
internal experience
so that we can show up in
the world the way we want to.
So this talk is going to
focus on the expertise
of our presenters, which
is to say mindfulness,
and in particular,
mindfulness and compassion.
But I also want to note that
mindfulness is not the only way
to deal with these.
In particular, connecting
with friends and family
is a great way of self-care.
Exercise.
Sleep.
Sleep is amazingly
supportive for this.
So there's probably a
number of other things
that are supportive
for you, and I
encourage you to really
pay attention to those
and make time for those.
But for this
session, we're really
going to be focusing
on mindfulness
as a means toward self-care.
And one thing I
want to point out
is that we're talking
about self-care
not as a way of
numbing or escaping,
although it's really reasonable.
When you feel bad,
you're just like, well,
I would like to feel better,
please, as soon as possible.
And some of the
strategies for doing that
are sort of suppressing
and turning away.
The real thing that's amazing,
what we're talking about here,
is this idea of actually
turning towards the difficulty
and turning towards your
internal experience.
But that's sort of a radically
counter intuitive, right?
So how do you do that?
How do you do that
when you feel bad?
And the answer is, compassion.
Compassion allows you to
hold difficult experiences
in a way that can keep
you focused on it,
but also focused
on other people.
And normally when we
experience strong emotion,
we're a puppet to that emotion.
It's sort of stimulus response.
By cultivating the
skills of self-awareness,
self-management, and
compassion, when you experience
these internal
feelings of discomfort,
you can actually
put a little bit
of a pause in there between
stimulus and response.
There's a great
Victor Frankl quote
of "In between
stimulus and response,
there's the capacity
for a pause.
And in that pause lies the
chance for our freedom."
So that's what we're
talking about today.
And once you're free of
that sort of automaticity
of behavior, then something
beautiful happens.
And the beautiful
thing that happens
is the opportunity to act
in the world in a way that's
in alignment with your values.
And this is the way
that we can both tend
to our internal experience while
also making the positive change
in the world that we want to.
It's this idea of an
engagement with ourselves
and with our communities
and with the systems
that we're a part
of it while also
tending to our own self-care.
So that's obviously
a pretty tall order.
So I'm about to hand it
off to two friends of mine
so they could do the
actual work of this.
It's sort of radically
counter intuitive.
So I have two dear friends.
One is Sharon
Salzberg, who is really
one of the meditation OGs.
She's one of the first people
to bring vipassana practice
in the current wave
to the United States
and really do a bunch of quite
beautiful translation of this.
She is one of the founders
of the Insight Meditation
Society in Barre,
Massachusetts, which
is one of the preeminent
vipassana centers
and schools in the west.
She is also the "New York
Times" bestselling author
of books like "Real Happiness,"
"Real Happiness at Work,"
"Real Happiness at the Dry
Cleaner," "Real Happiness
While Taking Out the Garbage."
No.
Getting back to real books now,
is "Loving Kindness" and a book
on loving your enemies.
And one of the
things that I really
enjoy about Sharon as a
student and also as a friend is
deep wisdom and knowledge
from some of the source wisdom
traditions that these
practices come from.
She really knows her stuff.
But it also seems
very real to me.
Like Sharon is also a New
Yorker who has seen some shit.
And there's an earthiness
and a saltiness
to the way that she
teaches that I find really
necessary, because my
relationship with compassion
has to exist in the real
world, and that real world
as is far from perfect,
as I started off with.
Also joining us
is my other friend
Phoenix Soleil, who is
a longtime meditation
practitioner.
She is also an
expert in something
called nonviolent
communication, which
is a class that's
available from time
to time here in Mountain View.
And let me know if you would
like the contact information.
She also offers coaching
and meditation mentorship.
She is also a teacher in
training at Spirit Rock, which
is one of the other preeminent
vipassana centers in the United
States.
And she is also a New Yorker
who has seen some shit.
So I should also point
out that I'm from Queens.
So we seem to have quite
the group of New Yorkers
representing in this area.
So please join me in welcoming
Phoenix and Sharon, who
will be leading us in some
practices and a little bit
of lecture and also
some exercises.
So thank you.
This is was put together at
extremely short notice again,
Phoenix.
So thank you very
much, and welcome.
PHOENIX SOLEIL: I'm so
happy to see all of you.
And I was really grateful
to be here a couple few days
ago at the New York office.
And it's interesting.
I was telling a lot
of people that I
noticed that after
doing that hour,
I noticed that I wasn't as--
I didn't feel as helpless when
I would read the news because
I had done something that
was in connection to my values.
And I just want
to compliment all
of you for coming
together here today
and people who are joining
us, because you're taking time
in your day to put some
attention on some really
difficult subjects.
Like I think one
of the ways that we
habitualized to deal with things
is push them away, you know?
And there's nothing
wrong with that,
because sometimes you have
things you need to do.
People have families.
You have jobs.
And sometimes you just can't
handle the feelings inside,
and it might be really
intelligent and smart to take
some time and say, I'm not
going to deal with this,
and I'm going to do whatever
is really urgent in my life.
What we know is that over time
there's a consequence to that.
It costs.
There's the stress involved,
because it's still there even
if we're not looking at it.
And that space that we're
putting it to gets full.
If we keep putting things in
it, it keeps getting full.
And then something small
happens with someone we love,
and we might lose our temper.
Or we cut someone off in
the highway, and you know,
it just builds up.
And then it becomes
like a volcano.
And we know, we see on the news
some of the effects of people
having volcanoes inside.
So right here you're doing
the difficult human job
of coming and facing the pain.
The other thing, though--
on the other hand,
the other way that we can
handle something difficult--
is to fall apart.
And I think that's what
causes-- a lot of us
choose the other one.
I'd rather push it
away than fall apart.
I'm afraid of being
so overwhelmed
that I won't function.
And as a New Yorker,
it's been bred into me
that I have to function.
You know, I've seen
all the "Rocky" movies
and I know that I'm supposed
to just get up there, put it
all to the side and win the
gold or whatever championship.
So those are the two pieces.
But then that falling apart,
does that help anyone?
You know, it's so
beautiful that as a human
we are affected by things.
But is that going to-- it's
beautiful, that sensitivity.
And we see what happens
when people aren't
connected to their sensitivity.
So what is the answer here?
And this is one of
the practice that
creates this other space
that's in the middle, which
is equanimity.
This creates this space where
you can process the pain,
and you can be with
it in this loving way.
And what you get to be is
able to see the big picture.
You're not consumed
by it-- and this
is how I sometimes feel-- and
you're not pushing it away.
And that is what we're
creating, and it takes time.
We have a culture
where it's like, you
want to take a quick pill.
And the quick pills don't
end up creating more safety
in this society,
for us internally
and for other people around us.
So I'm just going to check
in if there was anything
I wanted to start with.
The other important piece is
that sometimes taking that time
to do that self-care
can feel so selfish.
We want to do things, but
this is the preparatory work,
because when you're having a
conversation from that pain,
are you really open
to hearing someone?
Can you really bring
compassion to them
when you don't have
compassion inside?
When there's all this,
like, oh my god, I
can't stand this,
a lot of times we
don't have the
resource that we need
to be able to sit and think and
really look at the big picture.
Because I think the problems we
have, there aren't quick fixes.
These are these slow solutions.
They need the long range.
And I want to start with a sit.
And I want us to come into this
room and come into our bodies.
And it's interesting that
we talk about running away,
because I think focusing
on the breath is
a healthy way of running away,
in a way, because you are
connecting to your body
and you're connecting
to the experience of
being a human right now,
right now in this moment.
And whatever thoughts
you have about things,
you can put them on the
side for a little bit, OK?
So I'm going to ask
you to close your eyes.
If you don't feel comfortable
closing your eyes,
you can put your attention
on the floor or something
neutral like the wall.
And if you find
that what's inside--
you can keep your eyes open.
That's one of the suggestions.
And there's many kinds of
breaths that you can use.
I like this-- we're going
to take a long breath in,
and then what we're
going to do is
we're going to purse our
lips and let the air out
through our lips,
if people can see.
And you're pushing it
as long as you can.
Just a long exhale.
And you just let the tension
go out with your breath.
OK.
So let's take a deep
breath in and pause
and let the breath out
through your pursed lips.
Take another deep breath in.
And you can do this
on your own pace.
Don't feel like
you have to wait.
And take a pause.
And then I'm going to ask you to
do three more on your own pace.
Appreciate you doing
all that with me.
And then we're gonna count
from five to one, and at one,
please open your eyes and
bring your attention back
to the front of the room.
Five, four, three, two, one.
Thank you.
I notice that people's
expressions seem more relaxed.
Yeah.
I'm gonna pass it
over to Sharon.
SHARON SALZBERG:
It was at Google
that I first heard the term OG.
I had no idea what it means.
Do you all know what it means?
See, not everyone
knows what it means.
It means original gangster.
This is the first time
anyone ever called me that.
And I prize it.
Everywhere I go I say, you
know the best introduction
I ever had?
It was at Google.
It was Bill Duane.
He called me an OG.
So I did go to India quite a
number of years ago in 1970.
Came back in 1974 as
a meditation teacher,
a mindfulness teacher.
And it's kind of extraordinary,
of course, to see the wave,
and to see the new
prominence of the word.
And one of the concerns I have
about the word mindfulness
and the implications it
might have for people
is a kind of passivity,
you know, or complacency.
Like in a kind of immediate
way, I was leading a meditation
once, and we began
with listening to sound
before moving to the breath.
And I got no further than,
listen to the sound and someone
raised their hand
and said, well,
what if it's the sound of
the smoke alarm going off?
Should I sit here
mindfully knowing
the smoke alarm is going off?
Or should I get up?
And I said, I'd get up.
But the ways mindfulness
is defined correctly
often brings a kind
of confusion just
because of the associations
we have with the word.
Mindfulness means accepting
things the way that they are.
Mindfulness means being with
things without judgment.
Kind of sounds like
you're going to sit there
with the smoke alarm going off.
So metaphorically, I think
that's a good picture
of our time.
There are lots of
alarms going off.
And sometimes we can think,
oh, something like mindfulness
is going to give me the
ability-- it's like Bill said--
to sort of number out.
I'm going to just accept
things the way that they are.
I'm going to just be with
things without judgment.
And it's not quite
like sitting there
with the smoke alarm going
off being passive at all.
Really we're talking
about many levels.
We're talking about having
a dynamic relationship
with our experience
instead of, perhaps,
being so caught in habit.
We're talking about, just
as Phoenix was saying,
finding a place in the middle
where we're not necessarily
consumed by what's going on
because that really debilitates
us, or devastates us,
and doesn't necessarily
give us any room to act.
Nor are we going to
hate it and fear it
as a kind of cultivation,
like, you know,
I've been meditating
for 45 years.
I shouldn't feel this kind
of thing anymore, dammit.
You know?
It's just not useful,
either extreme.
And so there's a kind of
creativity in that energy.
And I feel it is very aligned
with the power of love
or the power of compassion.
I think one of the things I've
done in meditation practice,
or we do in any kind
of introspection
when we're really
looking-- doesn't
have to be meditation-- is
I felt like I really looked
at all the things--
probably not all,
but many of the things that
I'd been told were true.
Where does strength lie?
How alone am I?
What are the
divisions between us?
What's the reality?
Is a quality like
love or compassion
really as foolish and gooey and
sentimental and weak as I've
been taught?
Is vengefulness and hatred as
strong as I need in this time?
So I feel one of the
greatest gifts I've
gotten from my own
practice is that ability
to look with a kind
of rigor and honesty.
And it needs a
lot of compassion,
because it's not always
easy, what we see
in terms of our conditioning.
I feel like there's
a core within all
of that of recognizing
our wish to be happy,
to feel a sense of belonging
in this body and this mind
with one another, a
sense of home somewhere.
And even more than that,
almost like the right to that,
no matter who we are, no
matter what others tell us
about us, whatever stories
are told about us, that that
is really at the
core of our being.
And so I think mindfulness
is very connected to that
as well, as we practice.
And again, we can
practice mindfulness
a million different ways.
It doesn't have to be
through meditation.
But it's that quality
of looking and looking
with a kind of
sense of your own,
I'd say, innate dignity, that we
do deserve a kind of happiness.
And so I've practiced
with striking fast food
workers, for example, striking
for $15 an hour minimum wage,
and who are risking everything,
everything in their lives
to sort take a stand and say,
I have some worth as person.
I've sat with people
who have been subjected
to incredible violence,
or their families,
and have watched in awe
as people have tried
to work through where their
ultimate happiness might lie,
and how they might reweave
the story of what's
possible for a human
being based on the things
that they've gone
through and their wish
to make this a better world,
and not just kind of cycle
down and endlessly spiral down.
There are a lot of admirable
people in this world, I find.
We don't often hear about them,
perhaps, which is a problem.
But for me, the core of my
being able to venture forth
into some of these
terrains is-- having
had some shit happen
in my own life-- has
been really the
offering of some tools
so that these aren't
just idealistic notions.
And it certainly isn't
leading to a kind of passivity
or complacency, but
really some tools
to help me see through kind
of the myths I've been given,
work out of them, find
sources of strength
that I never imagined
were strong at all,
which is why I teach quite
a lot of loving kindness
meditation, which maybe we'll
do toward the end of our time
here together.
And of all techniques,
it's one where people often
approach it in the beginning
is, like, that's stupid.
How can that make a difference?
But like all things,
it's an experiment.
You know, it takes
a little risk taking
to see for yourself
if this is something
that might be onward leaning.
It does begin, I think, with
a kind of self-knowledge
that is very personal.
It's very insightful.
And this is really one of the
greatest powers of mindfulness.
These days when we
talk about mindfulness,
mostly we talk about things like
really enjoying your cup of tea
because you're
actually tasting it.
You're not so
crazily multitasking
while you drink the cup of tea.
And that's really good.
But classically, the
main goal of mindfulness
is to reveal our
lives to ourselves,
to understand so much more
about what's motivating us,
and what's onward leading,
and what's really bringing us
down, or even crushing us.
And then we know so much.
So one exercise I thought
we could do before we go on
is sit together
for a little bit,
have each person explore some
of the emotional terrain you've
experienced recently,
whatever that might be,
choose one really predominant
emotion, and look inside it.
Not why is it here, and what
am I going to do about it,
and should I switch therapists
or whatever, but you
know, what is this feeling?
First, what is it in my body?
And just take note of that.
And then see if you can watch
the movie of that feeling.
Sometimes if I'm working with
people over a period of time,
let's say it's something
like-- let's say
it's anger-- I'll say
next time we meet,
see if you can tell
me three things you
found inside the anger, and
one of them can be change.
Maybe there's sadness in there.
Maybe there's fear in there.
Very, very commonly, there is a
sense of hopelessness in there.
So just a few things.
And whatever is in
there, it's changing.
It's coming, it's going,
it's actually fluid, however
static or concrete we might
take it superficially.
So we'll do a little
bit of that together.
And then for those of you
who are, after the exercise,
going to be writing,
you can just
write it down for yourself.
Those of you who are here,
you can either write,
or we'll have you just speak
to one another if you wish.
OK?
So let's sit together.
And going back to the
refuge that is the breath,
because it really is a refuge.
As my early teachers
would say, you
don't have to believe anything
in order to feel your breath.
You don't have to
call yourself, you
know, I'm Buddhist or Hindu,
or reject anything else.
If you're breathing,
you can be meditating.
And as one teacher said--
I've always really thought
it was charming-- he said
the breath is very portable.
Right?
So you practice now.
We'll practice just
for a few minutes.
But then you're at work,
or you're somewhere
where it's very stressful,
or you're commuting,
and you're getting
really anxious,
really harried.
You can breathe.
Just rest of your
attention on the breath.
So it's right there for you as
a way of getting some space.
So again, you can have
your eyes open or closed,
however you feel most at ease.
See if you can find the place
where the breath is clearest
for you or strongest for you.
Maybe the nostrils, the
chest, or the abdomen.
Find that place.
Bring your attention
there and just rest.
See if you can feel one breath.
And if you find your
attention wandering,
don't worry about it.
Maybe your mind has jumped
to the past or the future,
judgement, speculation,
or you've fallen asleep.
Really, it's OK.
See if you can let go of
whatever has distracted you.
Let go gently.
And just bring
your attention back
to the feeling of the breath.
And see if you can bring to
mind just an array of emotions
you've felt in the
last week or two,
just what flashes through
you as you contemplate that.
It could be anything, from
anger to boredom, whatever.
And then choose one or two--
certainly one at a time--
and actually enhance it.
Strengthen it.
See what it feels
like in your body.
And to do this, clearly
you can't be lost
and, you know, this is the only
thing I'll ever feel forever,
or this is wrong to feel.
This is an experiment.
What does it feel
like in your body?
Then observe the movie of
it, the unfolding of it.
What do you see within it?
Just watch.
See what might emerge.
And remember that no
matter what you discover,
one of the characteristics
is going to be change.
It's going to be impermanence.
It's going to be movement.
Now when you feel ready,
you can open your eyes.
If you want to take
a few moments just
to reflect on what you
saw, maybe write it down.
I don't know if
there's anybody here
who wants to speak to the
person next to them or not.
I feel I've learned
some much myself
in doing that kind of
exercise, like look at how much
loneliness there
is in that desire.
Look at how much hopelessness
there is in that anger.
So I think we'll
take a few minutes
for questions or comments before
we go on with the program.
AUDIENCE: I was trying
to focus on what
I watched on
television last night,
and trying not to put
judgment into that analysis.
So I hear anger.
And so then I'm
like, OK, unpeel it.
There's fear.
But then I'm like,
there's ignorance.
But then, oh wait, I
don't want to judge others
when I'm trying to
understand them.
That's why I'm watching this
spectacle in the first place.
But I can't get
past that judgment.
SHARON SALZBERG:
You want to start?
You want me to start?
PHOENIX SOLEIL: Why
don't you start?
AUDIENCE: And I'm
looking for tools
to get past it, because
it's going to be
an interesting few months.
This affects every relationship
because friends and family
don't always agree.
Excuse me.
So insight.
SHARON SALZBERG: Yeah.
I wouldn't make assumptions
that everyone in this room
agrees, you know,
or wherever you
are, because that is also true.
And I think there's another
way of understanding the term
judgment, which is maybe not as
broad as our usual way, which
is, I think, the way
you were using it.
Because we have views.
We have discernment.
And there is such a
thing as ignorance.
Any of us can have
some knowledge
of how the universe works, and
hopefully growing knowledge
of how the universe works.
And if somebody is living
in defiance of that,
then there's discordance
and there's suffering.
It's just how it is.
Like if you-- from the
meditative point of view,
it would say if you completely
refute the idea of change,
you refuse to admit that
we're all going to die,
there's a society maxim
right there, right?
Stay in control of
everything all the time.
You can manage that.
Don't admit any vulnerability,
because you should
be ashamed of painful feeling.
And/or you don't deserve to feel
good, to let in the pleasure,
either because there's too
much suffering elsewhere,
or you just don't deserve it.
I mean, there's a million
things like that that
are ignorant that we all have.
And when they run our lives,
then we are suffering.
That's why we suffer, is
because we're so out of sync.
So there are some
almost scientific laws
of the universe.
Everything changes all the time.
And we are all connected.
We live in an
interconnected universe.
So what happens to some
group of people over there,
it never stays over there.
It filters out over here.
There is no over there anymore.
And science shows us that.
Environmental consciousness
shows us that.
Even epidemiology shows that.
Economics shows us that.
We live in an
interconnected universe.
So if you have a whole world
view that says that's not true,
it's kind of scary.
But that's different than
holding someone in contempt.
So when we use
the word judgment,
it's kind of specific.
It's feeling contemptuous,
or it's feeling so superior
that we can only
assume somebody is
coming from a really
damaged place to have
the view that they have.
There are lots of ways in which
we separate very strongly.
But that's one of the
fascinating things
about compassion.
There's like, how can you
have compassion for someone
and really feel they're wrong?
And do everything
you can to keep them
from being able to
affectuate their,
to your mind, wrong view.
I don't know that I want
people who really completely
disbelieve in interconnection
running climate
policy, or anything, really.
So I would work hard to try
to keep that from happening.
And I don't think
that has to come
from a place of real
hatred and alienation.
It's always useful, I
think, to look at ourselves,
and when we are the most
disconnected, what's
cooking in there?
And I hazard a guess that
we would find layers of fear
in ourselves.
And I would probably make
that assumption about others.
And I personally have not
been watching anything,
but I have a book deadline.
PHOENIX SOLEIL: Can
I say something?
SHARON SALZBERG: Please.
PHOENIX SOLEIL:
I think this goes
at the heart of one of
the gifts of meditation,
is being able to
hold the paradox.
I think what scares
people sometimes
about doing healing work is,
well, I'm going to be removed.
And is it OK that I
can have my safe life
and care for my loved ones when
so many horrible situations
in the world and
the environment.
And it's about,
can you hold both?
Because actually, the
thing is that the stronger
you are and the
more able you are,
the more you can bring to the
difficult things in the world.
But what some people can do
is try to isolate themselves.
And so it requires that strength
of being able to see both.
When you saw the judgment,
being able to also see the fear,
and to be able to see, oh yeah,
I could focus on this thought.
And that's what a lot of
us would do, is focus on,
this is all the ways
that they're wrong.
And you take a
breath, and then you
notice, well, there's
a sensation of pain.
There's also this feeling
of my feet on the ground.
There's the fact
that I'm breathing.
There's all of these things
happening at the same time.
And that is actual
health, is being
able to see and hold all of that
complexity, because when you
hold all that complexity,
instead of being overwhelmed
by, wow, this person is so
judgmental, you can hold,
yes, and we're all human
and we all have this.
And we also have
this vulnerability.
And we also have this incredible
urge to help each other.
Being able to hold that
thought at the same time
that you're holding the thought
of this particular human
being being so
difficult to be with,
that's being able
to hold a paradox.
And the other tool
I would bring is
that with nonviolent
communication, a lot of times
we have this thing called
translating the judgment.
A lot of times when
there's a strong judgment,
there's this need, this
beautiful human need
that's not being met.
And when you get to
that need, then it
changes your perspective,
because then instead
of focusing on
what's not working,
you're focusing
on what you want.
And that can be liberating.
AUDIENCE: One of the things
that has been unearthed
in this recent
series of experiences
is, for me, an ambivalence
around the idea of justice.
And I think part of
it is even a fear
of-- like an equating justice
with revenge that I think of,
sort of an eye for an eye, like
if you did something wrong,
then you should be punished.
And I'm just looking for
a different perspective.
PHOENIX SOLEIL: Yeah.
I think one of
the things I go to
is that I don't
think, as a society,
the medium has done a very good
job of showing alternatives
to punitive systems.
But there are lots
of people, and there
are countries who have
taken on practices
that are more about restoration
of trust and rehabilitation.
And they're
incredibly successful,
and most of the
time, less expensive
than a punitive system.
So part of it is
research, and knowing
that those things exist, and
really getting the evidence
that they work.
Because I think I remember
being a high schooler
and thinking that some
people are just bad.
And I think what's great about
doing practices where you're
looking at yourself is that
you get to see your quote,
unquote bad parts
and be like, huh,
this is similar
to that bad thing.
It's not the same scale.
But I can see how
this pattern works.
And when you can
see that, and you
start seeing shifts, even small
shifts, then that is giving me
a personal trust in the ability
of people to change, you know?
Because if I-- I'm just really
touched by your face right now.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
PHOENIX SOLEIL: Yeah.
I mean, I think
that's what excites me
about doing the work
that I'm doing, is
because when I started to see
my ability to change myself,
and I saw people who were
doing similar work-- now
I cry a lot out of happiness.
And that's that the holding
the paradox right there,
is that at the same time
that there's immense pain,
there's so many people who are
putting their lives at stake
to change things.
SHARON SALZBERG: It's beautiful.
And I think a lot of people--
of course, a lot of people
do use the word justice
to mean revenge.
And it's something I've been
afraid of for a long time
in this country,
because I could well
imagine it's just like too much,
and someone would seek revenge.
But the pattern of escalation
is so clearly laid out
in front of us,
and someone else is
going to turn on that
group-- seemingly group--
and then it's just
going to keep growing.
And as soon as the police
shooting in Dallas happened,
friends turned to
me and said, you've
been taking about this
for years, which I have,
because it scares
me so much, just
this kind of violent
escalation, which
is what every teacher
and person of nonviolence
has talked about.
And I've also seen, as
we have, the word justice
used in the most beautiful way,
which is really looking bigger,
looking at causes and
conditions for actions.
Why?
What makes somebody
choose a certain path,
or have a certain view,
or really understanding
these things don't just
happen, that we're all
coming from all these influences
and interactions and conditions
and socioeconomic
conditions, and everything.
AUDIENCE: Because so much of
contemplating cause and effect
seems so unjust,
that I could suffer
because of the circumstances
of my birth or benefit.
You know, that seems
profoundly unjust.
So it's confusing.
SHARON SALZBERG:
I mean, again, I
would say I would
look at justice
not as a sort of
rationale system
to answer the question
of why, but more
that clauses and
conditions exist,
that there's a kind of
lawfulness to the universe,
that things actually in
some level can make sense.
And I think if we are
moved to do that work
to try to make it a different
world, a better world,
we have to look at
causes and conditions.
Otherwise we're just
staying on the surface.
So for example, once in Barre,
where I co-founded a retreat
center, the Insight
Meditation Society,
we had a visiting
Thai activist who
was saying-- we were just
hanging out in someone's living
room and speaking.
And he was saying,
you know, if you
want to deal with
sex trafficking,
you've got to look at
Thai agricultural policy.
Why are those farmers starving?
Like, look deeper.
And that was
unforgettable for me.
I mean, we can't always
look deepest, you know?
But we can look deeper,
I think, in anything.
And then we see
ourselves in one another.
We see laws and conditions.
And we move where
our hearts take
us to see what we can address.
PHOENIX SOLEIL:
One of the things
that I do is I teach mindfulness
and emotional intelligence
tools to incarcerated youth.
And it's a beautiful
experience of the world,
because I will
see someone, and I
will hear a youth who's
been incarcerated,
and they will talk about
the incredible love
they have for their family.
And I will see the
tenderness that they
have for some of the
people they care about
and the lengths they have
gone to protect and to care.
And then sometimes,
there will be something
about some gang
or some situation,
and there's just no compassion.
There's just like, yeah,
they deserve to go,
and I have no problem.
And it's like, how
do you hold that?
And I had a friend who got
accosted and robbed in Oakland.
And she was in pain.
And she knows that
I do this work.
And she's like, I just
don't understand what
could lead someone to do that.
And again, it was
another paradox there,
because I was like, I
could tell her stories.
I could tell her so many
stories of young people
who are paying rent, or
who are homeless and are
trying to figure out how
to make food-- to eat.
But at the same
time, in that moment,
was someone with a cast.
And I was like this
is not the time
for me to bring in their story.
She needs to heal before
she can have space to hear.
So that's what I'm talking about
when I'm talking about what
we need in this society.
I think we're all walking around
with casts in different ways.
And we're also all walking
around with so much love.
And then that is so bad,
I just don't have space,
and I shut down.
And all the beautiful parts
of me aren't available.
And how do we work
with all this?
And that's what we do here.
We sit in it, so that we're not
just going to the next thing
and not processing.
We're sitting here and
we're being with it.
SHARON SALZBERG:
Certainly in this society
there's a tremendous
phobia about looking
at pain and suffering.
If it's your own, it's
cast as something shameful
or to be avoided.
If it's someone else's,
you'd rather tuck him
away soon so you
don't have to see it,
it's so unseemly that you are
displaying such suffering.
And that's a struggle many of
us have with our conditioning.
And interestingly enough,
I find myself these days
also talking a lot
about the relationship
we might have to joy and
pleasure and happiness,
not just because my books
are all called happy
something or other,
which are titles
the publisher
gives them, not me.
But it's intriguing to me.
I've spent so much
of my life trying
to come to terms with suffering,
and in a hugely important way,
you know, what's the
role of compassion,
rather than all that
separation and so on.
And it's just been
lately I've also
been kind of playing a
lot in the fields of joy
and happiness.
And part of it is also part
of that healing in this time,
because it feels so wrong,
somehow, to just take a moment
and enjoy something.
But in the end, we're
talking about balance.
We're talking about resilience.
We're talking about having
some sense of inner resource
so we don't feel so
utterly depleted,
because if we do feel utterly
depleted and overwhelmed
and shattered, we don't
have the wherewithal
to actually try to
make a difference
or even keep tuning in.
It's like too much.
I was talking to Bill before
a little bit about Russia.
And I always think about this
time I went to the Soviet
Union--it was still Soviet
Union in those days,
a long time ago in the '80s--
and I went with my friend,
my colleague, Joseph
Goldstein, to teach.
And it was actually illegal to
teach meditation in those days.
So we went as part
of a tour group.
And we even brought Joseph's
mother as kind of cover,
so no one would know
what we were doing.
And every afternoon we
would disappear, he and I,
and we would go off
with a translator
into someone's living
room, and we would teach.
And I found myself
speaking a lot
about compassion in those days.
And every time I did, I kind
of got this really-- there
was this really funny
feeling in the room.
So I finally sat down
with the translator
and I said, when I say
compassion, what do you say?
And they said, oh,
it's like this state.
You're miserable and
you feel horrible,
and you're broken by the
suffering that you see.
And it's like someone
has taken a giant stake
and driven it
through your heart.
And I thought, no wonder
there's a really funny feeling
in the room.
And it's like, oh.
But we can actually be
pretty close to that.
And it's not selfish.
It's not self-centered.
It's not weird to feel I need
a different kind of balance,
you know?
I need something that
is more uplifting,
that will give me that kind
of resilience and help me.
So that's very, very important.
And I did a program-- it was
a four-year program working
with frontline domestic
violence shelter workers.
And we asked in the beginning--
it was actually interesting
just in the context
of work-- so we said,
what's your greatest
stressor at work?
And this was all written so
you didn't have to disclose
anything if you didn't want.
And that was interesting,
because people
who did choose to
speak would sometimes
say surprising things,
like colleagues,
not sort of the hideous
workload or something.
But it was interesting
to look at.
And then the second
column was, what
do you do to kind of lift
your spirits, or get a break,
or get some
perspective on things?
And they'd write them down.
And then the third
column was, how do you
feel about the things you wrote
down in the second column?
So every single person, as far
as I know, through four years,
in that second column,
wrote down music.
It was all different
kinds of music,
but everybody wrote
down listening to music.
For some people they
were quote religious.
Other people it was nature.
And this is New York City,
you know, it's very gritty.
And sometimes people looked
at that second column
and they said, that's
what really helps me.
I'm not doing any of that.
That's not good.
Or maybe they wrote
down, I drink a lot.
And they'd say, I'm doing
a little too much of that.
Maybe I need to stop that.
And one woman who
did read her thing,
she said, I watch a lot
of "American Idol," which
I laughed.
I said, oh, I saw that once.
I got unbelievably stressed out.
For me it was like watching
continual rejection, you know?
There's not a way in the
world that, for me, it
would have helped.
And then we just said,
OK, here are these tools.
If you want to experiment
with them, here's meditation.
Here's yoga.
Here are these other things you
might try, because in the end,
you cannot go on in a good way
without both a sense of relief
and some experience of joy,
which could be very immediate,
somebody's smile, or a friend,
or something that will really
help us.
PHOENIX SOLEIL: And I
think that's why what we're
doing here is so important.
We talked about-- when we
were thinking about today,
it was like, well, when do
we want to have a dialogue?
When do we want to-- and it's so
important that that be set up.
And it also is important
that-- it's at a time--
because what I was saying
about walking around
with casts-- with what's
happening in the news,
I think it's like getting hit.
It's being really
emotionally hit.
And so we really need to
take care of ourselves.
And it's not being selfish.
It's getting prepared.
It's like clearing
the space so that we
can have those dialogues and
we can take those actions,
because I think all of us
want to create a better world.
And there's just different ways
of how to get ourselves healed,
how to heal the emotional
casts that we're in,
and these are one of the tools.
And some of it is being
able to take a break
and see the beauty in the world.
It's good for me to remember, no
matter what the headlines are,
there are hummingbirds.
There's water.
There's waves, there's the sun.
We're on a huge rock
orbiting a fireball.
Let's make this more fun.
SHARON SALZBERG: So this
is its own distinct method
of meditation, where rather
than resting our attention
in the feeling of the breath,
the sensations of the breath,
we rest our attention
in the silent repetition
of certain phrases.
So the phrases are ways of
paying attention differently.
So for example, if you
are in the habit of kind
of looking at yourself
at the end of the day
almost as though to
evaluate yourself,
like how did I do today?
And let's say you have the habit
of pretty well only remembering
the mistakes you made and
the things you could've
done better, and what you didn't
really like, let's just say.
So much so that your whole
sense of who you are,
and all that you
will ever be, just
collapses around that
really stupid thing
you said at lunch and a meeting.
So the practice of loving
kindness is one of gift giving.
It's offering wishing well.
So instead of fixating
on all those mistakes,
we kind of expand our sense of
who we are, like anything good
happen today?
Any good within me?
And it's not meant to be
deluded or wishful thinking.
You're not insisting, oh, wasn't
that a brilliant, witty thing
I said at lunch?
Maybe it was really stupid, and
there are consequences to that.
But that's not all that we
are, so it's that collapse.
So what do we look at?
So we pretty well only
look at what's wrong.
And who do we look at?
Who do we look through?
Who doesn't count?
Who is the other?
Not even just by dint
of prejudice or bias,
but just indifference.
So what happens when we look at
them rather than through them?
So all of this is done
through the silent repetition
of certain phrases.
Phrases are very simple,
like may I be happy,
may you be happy.
Being words, they
are quite imperfect.
I know that.
But it's a vehicle for us
to pay attention differently
and to include where maybe
we've previously excluded,
or to loosen the grip of
some of those fixations
on what's wrong and so on.
So we make that
offering to ourselves,
to all kinds of different beings
in our sphere, those we like,
those we don't like that much.
And we end with all
beings everywhere.
So there are a million
variations of this,
and I'll guide you
through one, OK?
So see if you can
sit comfortably.
You can close your eyes or not.
Let your energy just
settle in your body.
See if there are three or four
phrases that make sense to you
as this kind of offering.
Common phrases are things
like, beginning with yourself,
may I be safe, be happy,
be healthy, live with ease.
Live with ease means that the
things of day to day life,
like livelihood, like family,
may not be such a struggle.
May I live with ease.
May I be safe, be happy,
be healthy, live with ease.
You can use these phrases or
any phrases that come to mind.
Just three or four very general,
and repeat them over and over
again with enough
space and enough
silence so that it's a rhythm
that's pleasing to you.
I have a friend who
thought he'd get
extra credit by
saying more phrases
if he said them really fast.
You don't need to do that.
See if you can gather all your
attention behind one phrase
at a time, and then the next.
And the skill set is
really very much the same.
If your attention
wanders, doesn't matter.
See if you can gently let
go and just come back.
And then if there's
a benefactor, someone
who's helped you, maybe mentored
you or inspired you from afar,
bring them here.
Maybe say their name to yourself
or get an image of them,
get a feeling for
their presence.
And offer these phrases
to them, even again,
if the phrases aren't perfect,
they're like a vehicle for us,
they're serving us.
And then a friend, the first
friend who comes to mind.
Someone you find slightly
annoying, not really bad, just
a little bit.
Just see what happens.
And all beings everywhere,
all people, all creatures,
all those in existence.
May all beings be safe,
be happy, be healthy,
live with ease.
And when you feel ready,
you can open your eyes.
So thank you.
Thank you.
PHOENIX SOLEIL: Thank you.
SHARON SALZBERG:
Thank you, and you.
BILL DUANE: So thanks
to Phoenix and Sharon
for coming on very short notice.
Everything that we put
together has really
been sort of responding to
the needs of the community.
And in particular,
thank you to Richika,
who did all this planning.
For any of you have put
together a tech talk
or something similar, getting
a tech talk room on two days'
notice and putting everything
together is a huge feat,
so thank you.
In terms of follow on
resources, there's gPause.
And gPause is holding,
in particular, this sort
of compassion meditation.
Every day at noon Pacific
time, if you go to go/gpause,
you'll find the GVC,
so you don't have
to be in any particular place.
And then there's all the
other gPause programs.
In addition, there's also the
EAP, the Employee Assistance
Program, as well as gCalm, which
is a mindfulness-based stress
reduction system,
that online platform
that's doing quite well.
So with that, also thank you
for showing up for yourselves.
This is really challenging work.
And I think everybody who
shows up to do this work
is in a great position
to be a leader.
So thank you so much for coming.
Thank you guys.
SHARON SALZBERG: Thank you.